today's topic free range versus strict
parenting i know you want to talk about
spanking and different stuff like that
maryland parents are accused of child
neglect after allowing their two kids to
walk home alone from a park about a mile
away
what do you think about that letting
your kids walk home from a park a mile
away would you would you let your kid
no it depends how old they are but
everything that's going on right now
and i know my kids are gonna look a
little cute so
i'm not letting them walk away really
well it depends
where i'm at that doesn't even depends
where i'm at i'm not putting my guards
down it depends
how old they are it really depends how
old they are like i'm not kid what do
you
what do we mean kids what what do you
think me 15 is still a kid
16 but 12 is still a kid you know nine
as a kid
okay well five is again how old was the
kids they were like seven nate
nah you gotta look at your kid and you
have to say is my kid dumb
is my kid the kind of kid gonna be like
oh candies
it's a luxury to be a free-range parent
because there's a certain privilege that
goes with that
being a strict parent i think first of
all i
imagine stress should be a really fun
time of your life why follow all these
rules when you want to
enjoy your kids she looks like a
pre-race friend that's for sure
she's a borderline hippie that's right
here we go we we got we got
info being dropped by granola jenny
yo this girl looks like she grows her
own oatmeal
yeah that's pretty sure like christina
looked like
christina looked like um we about to go
in the store
don't look at nothing don't touch
nothing don't ask me for nothing
we go in there i buy the things i go
back on
if you ask me for something
um i'm jody and i'm the ceo of the
madden house
and i have eight children and i'm from
l.a
you know she popping out kids like she's
trying to make up for all white people
that's a lot of kids boo boo eight god
bless you
i founded the free range kids movement i
let my nine-year-old ride the subway in
new york city
by himself i wrote a column and two days
later i was on the today show
msnbc fox news and npr defending
my parenting style and i started free
range kids that weekend as a blog to say
look i believe in safety
i just don't think that we have to you
know have a security detail
every time we let our kids out of the
house so can i have
my free range parents on the left and my
strict parents
on the right see you later for ready
friends
children should be trusted to make their
own decisions
you walking forward on this one are you
going to stay behind it depends for what
i mean it's not black and white you know
what i mean people are trying to make
this
it's black it's white yeah yeah
yeah it's black it's white
yeah this one was a good song sorry it's
all good
michael jackson was black and white yeah
he was black and white
so technically michael jackson was great
listen to me
though black and white michael jackson
like would i walk it depends for what
like you know in this sentence you're
not giving me enough
information for me to be able to am i
walking or not like okay on what
i'm gonna be the annoying dude if i get
on these i'm gonna yeah but
you need to be more specific on what all
their decisions
so of course children should make their
own decisions i mean
we're trying to raise them so if you're
trying to raise them you
not
i can tell is going to be the most
detestable one on this panel we're
raising them to
you yeah you're raising them to be
responsible adults
if they don't make decisions they'll
never learn
when my child is possibly going to make
a bad decision
what i want to do is not tell him it's a
bad decision i think that's the wrong
thing to do because then
the ultimate is probably going to reject
that anyway also it depends on what
we're talking about decisions about like
if it's bedtime and you want your kids
to be in bed at eight o'clock i think
that is up to you
lennon's the more okay
newton is going to be the guy that's
going to be like uh like i'm just trying
to please everybody and i'm not really
saying much but yeah
jen we already know i think lenoir's
gonna be the more
bounced i think so all right but i
remember a time
my son called me he was 10 at the time
and he said mom
can i have another piece of banana bread
and i thought
i felt i felt bad because of course
that's a very simple decision they
expected that i was the one to decide
almost everything about what they were
eating and doing and i felt like
there was something wrong and that
actually started me reevaluating things
can they climb the tree just let them
climb the tree and what's the worst that
can happen they break an arm right
oh well what's the worst that could
happen if they jumped off a tree
break an arm it's easy for you to say
that about the broken arm
you know if you got health care right if
you have that privilege financially to
be able to afford
the treatment for your child great
imagine for poor families who when a kid
breaks his arm they got to go broke
right so you know earlier when the black
girl talked about privilege i didn't
know what she meant but i'm just
starting to see it right now it's like
yeah you can say all this stuff about
yeah do whatever you want the
consequences are the crowd no sometimes
they have huge financial repercussions
for their family
i know because i broke my arm when i was
a kid thankfully at the time i was
living in canada so treatment was mad
cheap
but if i was living in the states my mom
would have been like [ __ ] you crippled
now
why wouldn't they also let me whoop your
way your necks are yeah
well for my kids specifically she can go
outside and play after school and she
can
draw she can do whatever but there is a
very healthy boundary
like we don't have the type of
healthcare that
most people have so like no you can't
climb the tree
no you can't go up there and break your
arm because i'm gonna be in the hospital
that i'm gonna lose some time at work
then i'm gonna have to do extra work yes
go christian
probably that that jen does her own
plasters herself
out of kale and broccoli sticks if it's
like oh i don't want to play violin
anymore but it's like you can't
you're not allowed to quit things that
you start because even as an adult you
become a flaky adult
well you see so many parents nowadays
who just
like bend to every whim of their child
children should be trusted to make their
own decisions when it is wise
for them to make their own decisions you
know i'm not going to let my
five-year-old decide that he's not going
to brush his teeth anymore because he
doesn't
you know as the child grows and as you
as a parent train that child
then more freedom should be granted to
make their own decisions it should be a
true train our children
i feel like you train a dog and not a
kid i think terrain is a good word
i don't want a trained child okay well i
do
you know what this made me think of i
have chancer you know what the lana
trained that shot you know what i made
me think of it made me think of uh
we don't say mankind we say
people kind of you know what he meant
you just playing on words right now
you're an adult you're going to have
training you're going to attend a job
they're going to give you training it's
not training it's just you know more
like
information you really crucial
information that you need into
like to proceed into this job it's
called training do you know what
training is
education that's all yeah i'm not saying
to be like me do you think you need to
train them to be respectful or do you
think that you
guide them in a way to learn to be
respectful because of the decisions
they've chosen both
that's the training that's the mother
training you just don't like the word
because you're triggered
you god you train them it's all the same
thing these strict parents don't seem
that strict
they seem the strict ones are the
balanced one
the free range one by your guy
they do what they want that's the thing
is i think being strict is actually a
balance of yes you're gonna be able to
gradually make decisions that's why when
you have a permit
you learn how to drive you first have a
learner's permit
first you take some classes and
eventually you have
more and more responsibilities
she makes me mad man bro just eat a
granola bar
don't really follow rules even if it's a
theory of free range parenting per se if
you're following those
free range parenting rules then you
become strict
and i don't think that there should be
rules it should be
whatever the day brings
you embody everybody that i've
encountered
at the restaurant or the grocery store
that led the kid to whatever the [ __ ]
they want now i'm at the airport waiting
for my plane that's been delayed
it's not your kid's fault but the fact
that your kid
is jumping and streaming next to me and
you're in front
and you're not doing really yes to me
because there are no rules but yes there
are rules
and when that kid that never learned how
to play with rules
is going to encounter real rules it's
going to be a shock and tell you what
i can't let my kid my black kid
not have rules i can't jordan peterson
said something really interesting he
said
don't raise a child that other people
are
don't gonna a jackass he's free-spirited
no
he's messy sloppy as [ __ ] he's artistic
she's vandalizing he's high energy no
he's a kids reign your [ __ ] childhood
kids deserve privacy
maybe wait i don't know
absolutely yeah yeah
oh wait we have a struggler even though
not adults are still people and they
need
time to either hear their thoughts or
process things or just
they need a sense of comfort and
solitude and
things that are are sacred to them
in our household we live by this kind of
thought
live your life in such a way that if
everyone could see
what you're doing in private that you
wouldn't be ashamed
[Music]
i just peed that out that was
hypocritical you're a grown ass woman
you have kids
you did some things that felt good but
you're not really too proud of yeah yeah
you did the grown-up you did your taxes
you and your husband you balance
numbers you balanced your budget he made
a deposit
god bless you but i ain't masturbating
in front of my siblings
uh it's not gonna happen i'm not ashamed
that was crazy talk to me
ashamed so you can so my kids also look
through my phone
privacy is not something a child should
be entitled to have
do we give our kids quiet down time yes
am i looking for all their stuff no um i
actually agree
with the definition of downtime and
privacy at my house there's no privacy
because you don't pay any bills
she also trusts me and i wanted to make
a relationship to where she trusts me
that
even if she came to tell me like there's
no yell i don't yell and i don't scream
and i don't do anything like that
we're very open but there is no privacy
so i just wanted to put in a plea though
for some privacy
you know i go around and i talk about
free-range kids and sometimes what i ask
the audience is to tell me
when something did go wrong and i asked
them
did you tell your parents what do you
think they said no
why do you think they said it fear fear
fear of what
being in trouble being yeah you think
it's trouble they said they didn't want
their freedom taken away
i think it's important though that we
hold our children accountable because
in the world there are plenty of
adults who are not held accountable
who've never been held accountable and
they just do things
that are terrible but most of childhood
is
little things and you don't have to be
there for everyone because
that's when kids start realizing i can
handle this
parents should be parents and not
friends
i'm the parent and you're the child
because i don't want you to lose respect
for me
like i'm not gonna go clubbing with my
daughter like there's just some things
that i'm just not gonna do
that i do with my friends that i'm not
gonna do with my kid i agree that i'm
their mom
first but i'm also their friend i'm also
someone that they
trust and admire and they come to and i
listen to them and i give them my
opinions and we have
forged a friendship but it's not without
my position as the authority in their
life okay listen
if you're my boss you're not my friend
if at any point you could tell me what
to do when i have to follow your orders
we're not equals i am below you
there's a reason why friendships between
subordinates and their superiors is
always very touchy
because at any time you can pull rank on
me so how am i supposed to see you as my
equal
you not you're not you're not friends
with your kids
at least not until they're adults you
can be friends with your kids if you
want to but i know damn well i'm not
gonna be friends of mine
i'm your father but it doesn't mean that
you cannot come to me as a father i'm
gonna give you
i'm gonna give you uh insight on life as
a father i have a father i didn't want
him to be my best friend
doesn't mean that we're not going to be
good doesn't mean i'm not going to laugh
with you
and we're not going to have fun you know
it's not that that's not what it means
it just means that i'm the dad
that's the hierarchy point that's the
that's the level
in my mind once my kids are 18 or
let's just say moved out of the house
they are an adult and at that point i
want to
stop parenting if i haven't parented
enough
by the time they're 18 then i should
then that was my
chance i don't want to be a parent after
18.
this is gonna step back a bit because
wow granola jet is some [ __ ] up kid
wow jam
jen has kids but doesn't want to do a
lot of stuff huh
i don't want to parrot i don't want to
train
i don't want to be a parent past 18. i
don't want to wow
you just had kids to have kids but
you're not taking none of these
responsibilities
i don't want to make lunch and when it
comes to clubbing i
hope that when my kid is old
and grown up and they're going out for a
beer at a bar or whatever they're doing
of course i want to come with them
can you imagine they're like juveniles
back that ass up comes on
hey mommy hey and then she's just
twerking and [ __ ]
she's like yeah oh mom go get him he
look cute you know
hey spanking your child is an acceptable
form of punishment
what are your thoughts banking is an
acceptable form of punishment
sure i'm spanking any [ __ ] okay
yeah do you think that they're gonna
have memories
of these times being spanked and that it
will be
sure something thankful for it i would
do
because i i mean i would be lying if i
said i
never have spanked my child of course
but i don't ever i don't
don't feel good about it it doesn't
matter if you feel good or not you're
judging people on things that you did
but because you think it's good and you
feel good about it
you're bad you're worse than me no
you're as bad you did that you resort to
that
so your ass bad don't you want to raise
your child to not want to do things
because they feel as if they'll be a
better person
not because they're going to be punished
for it both
see this is hard for me to understand
because i come from a culture where
everyone like all my friends have loving
parents that spank them as kids and now
they've grown up to be great functional
well-functional adults who respect their
parents and are glad their parents
spanked them
i'm not going to talk someone that
spanks their skin their kids i'm not
going to be like
you shouldn't thank you that's that's
true do you you know what i mean
uh i don't want to initially this isn't
my kids the same way
but and also i am thankful that my
parents
did it sometimes because sometimes up so
i understand this point
generally uh spanking is a bad form of
parenting
uh science is pretty conclusive on this
it normally
uh it's a very strong correlation with
kids in violent behavior
there's a higher likelihood of it
there's a higher likelihood of that
child uh social anxiety
uh i don't think it was depression but i
definitely think
in terms of violent tendencies
much more likely and to me you know it's
been confirmed by sociologists that
spanking
does raise those and i'm not surprised i
think if you see
somebody resolve an issue through
physical actions
then you as a child internalize that as
a
as a valid way to deal with certain
problems and so
it becomes a perpetual cycle because the
way you see your parents
because you heard them say before is
that it's the easiest most effective way
to solve a problem
it's effective and it's the easiest way
for you
it's not necessarily what's in the best
interest of a child because
you're telling that child that the
solution to their mistake
is physical action and so what ends up
happening is that when they encounter a
problem
their response to it is more likely to
be physical because if that's what
they've learned from you
yup it's why people who grew up in crime
areas
tend to replicate crime themselves i'm
not saying it's going to be the case i'm
saying
it's far more likely so whether his five
kids are fine or not
that remains to be seen and that's
irrelevant just because their five kids
are doesn't mean that it's a good way to
parent other children
so you can parent your kids however you
want i'm not here to tell you i'm just
telling you what the facts are
and then everyone has to make their own
decisions after that but you going to
thank your kids
no i'm not because my mom didn't need to
spank me
and i felt like the way she parented me
in regard and compared to the
all the other strict kids around me was
way better and she parented me
differently because my
older siblings were parented very
strictly just
first kids they always tried yeah yeah
and it didn't work out so well
and so when i came along it was kind of
like and i was given a lot of space to
make mistakes
and i think once i was given that space
to make mistakes my mom just said be
responsible and i think as a young man
we all want responsibility
we want to we want to feel like we're
contributing like we're part of the
process do you know what i'm saying
and so when you're given that
responsibility and people really respect
you with it
then you don't want to let them down you
know what i'm saying because that's like
i'll give you an example an army well
i've told you the story already but when
they would punish us
you can't hit nobody in the military and
so what they would do is they would
punish everyone else around you for your
mistakes
so that you felt responsible and ashamed
of the fact that you let the others down
and so once you've seen that you felt
like garbage and so you would
you would improve the way you behaved in
order to make sure you didn't let the
people around you down
and i think that's an effective way it
teaches you that your actions
don't just have repercussions on
yourself but the people around you and i
just felt like
all those different ways that i saw
myself being shaped that didn't require
violence made me realize you can
make someone realize the impact of their
actions without hating them
i just think hitting them is effective
because it instantly settles the
situation
you don't have to take the time to
explain to them you don't have to take
the time to reach that child
and actually get to explain the
situation to them in a way that they can
understand
absolutely you hit them and they're ow
and they don't do it anymore you know
what it's not necessarily true that
they're not going to oh no i know plenty
of kids who were spanked and hit and
they became some of the worst people i
know
exactly so it doesn't mean that it's
going to be that effective actually no
okay i'm just gonna tell say my my view
so
i don't spank my child one because of
child slavery
and jim crow i'm a black person and i
live in a world
where black people are beaten all the
time
i have a mother who spanked me i'm not
glad that i was spanked
i respect her but i'm not happy about
that also the same thing with the people
who are like i was spanked i came out
great
they usually have like anger issues
they're violent they whip their own kids
they probably need therapy
she's just my girl chris is my girl she
knows what the hell she's not holding
back no punishment
but she don't need to hold back go go
christian
go girl live your life let's hit it i
sometimes
fear i am raising my children the wrong
way
they they should all go forward every
single one of them
if you don't raise a child and don't
think to yourself
maybe i'm doing this wrong at any point
to me that means you lack self-awareness
or that your ego's involved the only
person i think that should stay back
is christian i think part of parenting
is always worrying
i mean as hard as i try to do the right
things
you know there's always doubts in your
mind that you've done something wrong
i love to tell parents especially new
ones that we're all winging it
we're making mistakes every day but the
good thing about it is that our kids
still love us they still look at us like
mommy
and their fries right right
club buddy
even free range lenora's flying jetty
club buddies
friends right she not playing games man
get your petty on girl oh that's good i
ain't mad at it
so black parenting is literally just
like one huge ass experiment
that's a nice expression you know
parenting is one huge ass experiment
people think that i have the answer
because i wrote free range kids and i
run this let grow and all i can say is
that
believing in your kids you know
believing in them whether you give them
a time out or you're spanking them
believing that your kids
have this capacity for for being a
decent human being and they're going to
make mistakes they're going to be okay
that's what kids want it's really funny
how
the strict parents were actually the
ones
that were most balanced and one of the
free range
leonard was one that was balanced too
but she's she was writing it so please
show everybody raising kids
but the free range i'm not with the free
range thing i think i consider myself as
a strict parent
according to their standards but it's
really not always
black or white it's really a career area
you know use common sense
the thing is no parents really know what
they're doing
that's pretty much it that's it for
today tell us what you think
uh follow us on a different uh platform
if you want more content
don't forget to go on the patreon and
check that out uh we have a bunch of
different things that we're gonna
that we're gonna put out and yeah that's
pretty much it uh i'm preach
because apparently you messed up i was
down
see you another time